[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
le football brésilien c'est Pelé les
Français en savent quelque chose
s'appeler il ne réfléchit qu'une bouchée
du Brésil oui mais voilà Pelé leur a
coupé les jambes avec son premier
important l'équipe de France était en
vert regardez cela il s'en donne à cœur
joie les avants français
toutes ces combinaisons finissent par
être payantes
voilà comment vesney ski est gagné
alors Monsieur Pelé reprend le Bricoman
de son équipe il donne des frissons aux
défenseurs français Bonnel perd la tête
il faut que j'arrête verset
penalty Pelé se fait un second but et
puis il rentre à nouveau dans sa
coquille
les avants français ressortent le grand
jeu de 800 tête lui c'est le Pelé de
l'équipe française il va le montrer dans
un instant voilà comment de la BU à ses
partenaires
[Applaudissements]
m’épeler lui il préfère marquer tout
seul ces bus et ce qu'il fait et on peut
dire que c'est lui qui a battu l'équipe
de France qui d'ailleurs ne méritait pas
de perdre
il est long le chemin qui mène à la
gloire et c'est sans doute pour cela que
les bébés matador espagnol prennent les
devants
on fait timidement connaissance avec le
fauve lui aussi un bébé un bébé taureau
guerre plus rassuré il est vrai
courageux mais pas téméraire
enfin c'est le grand moment le matador
affronte le monstre
ce n'est plus un faux c'est un lapin ce
rôle à l'école
[Musique]
le style de la nouvelle vague avec le
taureau ce serait sans doute une autre
histoire
[Musique]
mais tout de même maman est fière de son
petit prodige
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
un petit prodige qui attendra de ne plus
pleurer pour être un homme et qui aura
encore l'occasion d'apprendre qu'il est
vraiment très long et douloureux le
chemin qui mène à la gloire
[Musique]
voyage du général de Gaulle Saint-Dizier
aura été une étape importante le chef de
l'État y a rencontré le maire de Berlin
Ouest monsieur Willy Brand et a évoqué
avec lui le problème de Berlin et
l'avenir de l'Europe
[Musique]
Colombelles les deux églises par contre
où le voyage prit un aspect privé fut
une étape de détente consacrée en
quelque sorte aux relations de bons
voisinage
à Chaumont de nouveau le président de la
République devant une foule considérable
à traiter des problèmes de la
construction de l'Europe
[Musique]
si ce voyage fut émaillé lui aussi
d'arrêt surprise Amani le général de
Gaulle teint à Salvé deux couples de
jeunes mariés il fut comme les
précédents celui des grands thèmes ce
que le chef de l'État a repris à 3
l'Europe l'Alliance atlantique la
détente le rôle de l'État et la
solidarité nationale
[Musique]
dans la banlieue de New York un banal
feux de broussaille a bien failli
tourner à la catastrophe favorisé par la
sécheresse inhabituelle de ces dernières
semaines et attisée par un banc violent
les flammes se sont propagées à une
vitesse foudroyante à travers une zone
résidentielle située entre Bayonne et
Lucson des milliers de pompiers venus de
New York et des environs aidé par de
nombreux volontaires ont lutté toute une
journée pour faire au feu une part
exceptionnellement belle 500 maisons et
1200 hectares calcinés par miracle il
n'y a que quatre morts la plupart des
demeures détruites étant des chalets de
week-end encore inoccupés
[Musique]
depuis quelques temps Vito petite
bourgade de Côte d'Or s'interrogeait
[Musique]
évident de perplexité il y avait les
pour et les contes il est vrai que la
question était de taille laisserait-on
détourner la route nationale trop
étroite ou pour la garder au milieu de
la commune
sacrifierait-on les halles des Halles
tout de même du 14e siècle
maintenant plus vitaux organisa son
référendum et c'est ainsi que les
habitants d'un petit chef-lieu de canton
ce singularisèrent ce dimanche là en
prenant le chemin des urnes
la belle affaire direz-vous mais si Vito
allait être imité on ne sait jamais
exactement où commence une épidémie on
l'a bien vu avec le twist en tout cas il
n'y a plus de problèmes à vitaux
allègrement par 35 oui contre 65 non la
bourgade de Côte-d'Or a opté pour
l'élargissement de la rue
[Musique]
à l'abbaye de Westminster en présence
d'un parterre de têtes couronnée et de
2000 invités la princesse Margaret et la
reine Elizabeth sont venus assister au
mariage de leur cousines la princesse
Alexandra
conduite par son frère le duc de Kent
celle que les Anglais ont surnommé la
princesse souriante va être unie à
l'honorable vie second fils du comte
derli
[Musique]
c'est l'archevêque de Canterbury qui
célèbre le mariage selon le rite
anglican douzième dans l'ordre de
succession au trône la princesse
Alexandra a souvent remplacé la reine et
la princesse Margaret dans certaines
cérémonies officielles
[Musique]
derrière la traîne longue de 20 pieds on
a beaucoup remarqué la princesse Anne
devenue très jeune fille
[Musique]
la princesse Marina ma mère de la mariée
a été profondément ému du triomphe fait
par la foule aux jeunes époux qui vont
partir pour l'Écosse terre des ancêtres
de Monsieur Oggy
[Applaudissements]
c'est la fleur la plus répandue de tout
le règne végétale elle prolifèrent de
l'Amérique à l'Himalaya de Bali à Tahiti
et pourtant on lui consacre de
laborieuse culture insère en
Île-de-France par exemple des études
minutieuses et des soins attentifs lui
ont apporté la perfection lui ont
constitué son Gotha
[Musique]
tels sont en effet les orchidées d'une
graine il est toujours possible
d'obtenir mieux que la fleur qui la
produite mais au prix de quel patience
sélectionnez dans de petites
centrifugeuses les graines sont
ensemencées une à une dans une gélatine
très sucrée celle-ci remplace les
champignons auxquelles les graines
sauvages empruntent habituellement leur
substance nutritive
[Musique]
un cycle qui va durer de 9 à 10 ans
depuis l'instant où la boule de pollen
est déposée sur le stigmate de la plante
jusqu'à celui qui verra éclore le
premier bouton sur le nouveau pied
d'orchidée
[Musique]
ils sont nés dans les serres de la
tuilerie à Boissy-Saint-Léger pour être
exporté à travers le monde plus de 1000
variétés de ces fleurs étranges
le moins curieux n'est pas originaire
des tropiques les orchidées créent en
Île-de-France repartent par avion vers
leur pays d'origine pour y orner les
boutonnières ou les appartements c'est
lire le prestige des orchidées de
culture comme le fascinant l'inquiétant
sabot de Vénus
[Musique]